Усім привіт, це Ева Зу Бек для програми DW Travel,
і сьогодні я запрошую вас на пригоду в гори України.
Але перш ніж ми вирушимо, я покажу вам Львів,
культурну столицю цієї прекрасної недооціненої країни.
Ходімо!
Львів - це точно прихована перлина Європи.
Місту понад 800 років, і завдяки своєму стратегічному розташуванню
протягом століть воно переплавило у собі культуру сходу та заходу.
Тут все надзвичайно яскраво і, перш за все, абсолютно приголомшливо.
Але лише за пару годин від Львова ви знайдете зовсім інший світ.
Тут, у таємничих Карпатських горах, розташовані крихітні села
із багатовіковими традиціями.
Я їду до Шибеного - села, в якому живуть гуцули,
корінний етнос цього регіону.
Гуцули – слов'янський народ з власною культурою, діалектом та історією,
який живе у цій частині України та сусідній Румунії від незапам'ятних часів.
Традиційно це були вівчарі, скотарі та лісоруби,
які жили в гармонії зі своєю землею.
Вони особливо відомі різьбленням по дереву, вишивкою та ремеслами.
На сьогоднішній день, за оцінками, налічується лише близько 25 тисяч гуцулів.
Ласкаво просимо до віддаленого села в країні гуцулів.
Я все вам покажу.
Шибене справді на самісінькій окраїні,
прямо поруч з румунським кордоном.
За селом - гори та ліси на кілометри.
Це традиційне село з безліччю прикладів місцевої гуцульської архітектури.
Я приїхала у гості до родини Максим'юків.
Як і багато гуцулів, вона займається традиційним бджільництвом.
Ми - сім'я Максим'юків, Іван і Марія.
Проживаємо в селі Шибене Верховинського району.
Разом ми в парі 42-ий рік!
42 роки! - Так, 42!
Просимо у Бога за світле безхмарне небо, за всіх хороших людей,
за діточок своїх, людських. І просимо людей приїхати до нас.
Сім'я запросила мене дізнатись про їхні традиційні вулики,
які вони тримають відразу за своїм будинком.
Ці дерев'яні вулики Іван побудував своїми руками.
У мене таке відчуття, що він не просто будував вулики для виготовлення меду.
Він так захоплюється бджолами, що хотів збудувати їм дім у власному саду.
Я не фахівець з бджільництва. А це означає, що я маю одягнути це, щоб захиститися.
Марія зробила нам усім невелику димну ванну, щоб бджоли нас випадково не вжалили.
Вулик протягом усього року тримає теплу температуру
завдяки надійній дерев’яній конструкції та товстій подушці, яка ізолює вулик зсередини.
Тепло необхідне, щоб бджолам було приємно і комфортно.
Ось це - робочі бджоли.
Ці бджоли збирають пилок,
а потім у вулику переробляють його на мед.
Іван та Марія пояснили, що робочі бджоли можуть пролітати відстань
до п’яти кілометрів і повертатися з пилком із диких квітів на полонинах.
А ось бджола-матка, найбільша бджола у вулику.
Її функція - підтримувати роботу колонії як єдиного цілого, а також відкладати яйця
для майбутніх поколінь бджіл.
Вони пишаються тим, що їхній мед -
настільки органічний, що не містить хімікатів і цукру. Як і задумано природою.
Як він про мед розказував, ви розумієте, оцей наш карпатський,
він є такий, що переваг йому нема. Ми дамо вам попробувати.
Нарешті, настав час мені скуштувати цей надприродний гуцульський мед.
Подивіться на цей прекрасний натуральний мед прямо з вулика!
Немає нічого свіжішого за це.
Боже мій, це так смачно, так солодко.
Такий свіжий, такий природний і, чесно кажучи,
на смак як ліс, ніколи не їла такого меду.
Мене вразив цей традиційний вулик, який утримують у гармонії з природою.
Але, звичайно, гостинність цим не обмежилася.
Марія запросила мене залишитися на обід.
Ще теплий!
Цей хліб ще теплий!
Такий свіжий.
Гаразд, давайте розріжемо!
Марія готувала цей свіжий хліб власноруч.
Жінки в її родині вдосконалювали ці домашні рецепти упродовж поколінь.
Перший шматок цього прекрасного домашнього сільського хліба.
Так смачно!
Він просто ідеально хрусткий зовні,
м’який і пухкий всередині, і все ще теплий.
Жодних хімікатів, нічого, лише натуральні інгредієнти, 100% домашній.
Я б точно змогла тут жити.
О, найсмачніший свіжий сільський компот.
Це щось на кшталт розбавленого соку. Компот справді
дуже популярний у всій Східній Європі.
Домашнє масло і сир.
Домашній маринований перець, і звичайно ж, свіжий хліб.
Чесно кажучи, я б залюбки так обідала щодня.
Свіжий домашній сир.
Всі ці продукти - з цього домогосподарства. Усе зроблено тут.
Сир зроблено з молока місцевої корови, яка живе тут, у сараї позаду мене.
Абсолютна органіка!
Ви не купите такі речі в супермаркеті. Не зможете купити.
Лише тут, у цьому маленькому селі.
Перш ніж відпустити мене, Марія хотіла, щоб я приміряла традиційне гуцульське вбрання.
Ух ти!
Настав час продемонструвати мій новий гуцульський вигляд.
Ось так!
Це традиційний одяг гуцульської жінки.
Гарно.
Оскільки я розмовляю польською, а родина розмовляє
гуцульським діалектом української, ми могли порозумітися досить легко.
Скажіть, як називаються всі ці елементи одягу?
Це кожух. Кептар.
Гердан.
Сорочка.
Попружка.
Запаска.
І це дуже традиційний гуцульський наряд?
Пані Єва, це традиційний гуцульський наряд.
У горах Польщі є  гуральський народний стиль,
а у нас традиційний гуцульський стиль.
Це не повсякденний одяг.
Це одяг, який вдягають на свята, коли ходять до церкви, і, чесно кажучи, це так красиво.
Усі його елементи виготовлено вручну, вишито вручну, все від А до Я.
Ви ніде не побачите такого одягу, і, звичайно, не придбаєте його в звичайних магазинах.
Це прекрасний витвір мистецтва.
Попрощавшись із родиною Максим'юків, я вирішила зробити ще одну зупинку в селі.
Пан Микола є останньою людиною в цьому селі, яка досі робить ці традиційні
гуцульські дзвони пастухам для тварин, яких випасають тут, у цих прекрасних горах.
Це ставлять на коні, на корови.
Щоб коли тварина піде в ліс, її легше знайти.
А цей вже має інший звук.
Кожен дзвоник має свій неповторний голос.
А такий для коней - щоб коли сані їхали, дзвінок дзвоне.
Отакі дзвінки.
Відвідавши гуцульське село Шибене, я зрозуміла,
наскільки недооцінена ця частина України.
Крім мене в селі не було жодного туриста, і тут рідко можна побачити іноземців.
Окрім багатих традицій та казкових ландшафтів,
можливо, саме це робить село настільки затишним,
автентичним і таким, ніби ти потрапив у минуле.